[Music]
at night
and the morning after balloons and
nitrous oxide canisters litter parks and
public spaces this new party accessory
is proving to be a growing problem
we asked is the government planning to
ban laughing gas nitrous oxide yes so
this would be under the 1971 misuse of
drug site Class A Class B Class C I
didn't know which class we would um
attribute to it but we would we want to
make sure that the uh the sailing use
can be restricted for its appropriate
purpose we can't have a situation we
mustn't have a situation where uh our
parks are public spaces become drug
ticking Arenas scientists warn that
would mean new penalties new sentences
and a whole new set of people
criminalized we seem to have moved from
what is an ASB and a decision Behavior
type activity to no criminalizing young
people and older people for something
that does not deserve the evidence base
clearly states that this is not a
recommendation that should go forward
there is no
to quote substantive evidence of the
link between nitrous oxide and
anti-social Behavior it's what the
government's own advisory body said too
despite some cases of severe injury from
inhaling the gas it said the risk isn't
high enough to Warrant a ban instead it
advised the tackling of illegitimate
sales because unlike other ban drugs
nitrous oxide has intended purposes like
in catering as a propellant to make
whipped cream or to make cars go faster
in Drag Racing but mainly in hospitals
and dentists for pain relief all of
these sectors will no doubt have
questions about what this ban means for
them but at this Youth Club in West
London young people already fear the
worst a criminal record at this age
could have lifelong consequences it's a
good thing as long as it doesn't harm
the criminal record because that could
come to bite them later on in life when
they're looking for employment I think
that if the policing gets fed taking
taken further a lot of communities will
feel discriminated against in England
nitrous oxide is the second most
commonly used substance among 16 to 24
year olds
now the seemingly soft party drug could
land you with hard consequences Sadia
chowdry Sky News